jared stidham the presumed starter in
new england until cam newton came along
in late
june
statement practice yesterday had three
interceptions remember when marcus
mariota was a rookie in tennessee
four years ago right five years ago 2015
god world five years ago it was that
marcus mariota it's been that long that
it was every day the breathless headline
no interception jet practice for marcus
mariota no interceptions yet well jared
stidham had three yesterday in practice
for the new england patriots and
aaron rodgers i recall at the time chris
was very blunt about this i i want to
throw in receptions in practice that's
how i determine how big the windows are
with my receivers sure that that's how i
figure out how much i can trust my
receivers i'm going to throw in
receptions that's the time to do it now
i don't know why jared stidham threw
three interceptions yesterday but it
becomes noteworthy when you're competing
with cam newton and brian hoyer and
they're rotating they're splitting the
reps one two three the problem is it
keeps the guy who's eventually going to
be the starter from being as prepared as
he could be
what do you read into first the notion
that jared stidham had three
interceptions at practice i i don't read
really anything into it other than you
know it's like hashtag as expected yeah
you mean you know the guy who's taken
over for tom brady and hasn't played a
lot of nfl football going against you
know one of the greatest defensive
coaches and probably definitely the best
secondary in football with a lot of
young pieces on offense to go along with
stidham who were learning it you know
i'm not shocked by that you know yeah
it's news because it is cam newton and
jared said him and the patriots and tom
brady's not there so i understand that
but but to me what i always want to go
when i hear these type of stories is the
context of the interceptions right
that's the first thing i want to hear
you know wait was was one a perfectly
thrown ball and it you know bounced off
the receiver's hands and got intercepted
uh was one a time where the receiver was
supposed to break in and he broke out
and jared you know so those are the
things i need to hear
to then understand the context of the
interceptions and what's going on there
let alone
hey listen you know sometimes you have
themes in a day i was there in a year
when new england in the otas mic where
you know they like because brady was
unwilling to push the ball down the
field they were unwilling they were
willing to have him do that and pass up
incompletions and practice and do things
because they this is what they wanted to
work on so you never know too whether
the coach went hey no check downs today
i want us to push the ball down the
field i want you to test these corners i
want to see what our receivers got you
know so some of those interceptions
maybe that was said before a period i
don't know maybe not i'm just throwing
out different things that could be the
possibility so where we don't just go oh
jared simon stinks he do three
interceptions benjamin cam newton's a
starter it's over you know i'm just
trying to add some context to that
situation
when you were there did they also
practice with footballs having different
degrees of inflation did they do that
too see which would be best
i'm not gonna start don't get me going
gloria
no i'm i'm kidding i'm kidding and and
i'm on record as number one the whole
thing was a sham and number two who
cares how much hair is in the football
the whole idea is we want to make it
easy to throw the football matt casey
says next yes hey matt casey i got the
microphone on yeah tell him that's right
i choose not to shut it man
now uh remember last year the guy that
threw five interceptions
right in the super bowl yeah jimmy
garoppolo of course of course he didn't
make the one throw that would have made
him the super bowl champion potentially
unless and until patrick mahomes drove
down the field with the winning
touchdown which is probably what would
have happened anyway i mean that's
probably the one post script to jimmy
garoppolo missing emmanuel sanders when
he was open for the go ahead score
probably patrick mahomes goes down the
road and wins the game based upon what
we saw from mahomes leading up to that
point so it doesn't matter uh and it
doesn't matter when you're throwing
receptions in practice unless like you
said it's it's all on the quarterback
and you can't tell without knowing the
context of the practice the specifics of
the throw why the guy threw the
interceptions and the reality is stidhum
hoyer newton are in it and i mentioned
the platoon possibility last segment for
the bears mike reese of espn.com
has floated the possibility as
opinion analysis but sometimes we hear
things in report yeah sometimes our
guesswork is more than that and you just
have to tread lightly because you don't
want to compromise sources
mike reese suggesting that maybe there
will be a platoon system when we get to
the regular season and it won't surprise
me and if belichick does it he'll be a
genius because he's already a genius but
the idea is
we can't fully evaluate these guys until
we see them against someone else we
can't practice against someone else we
can't play against someone else until
week one so we have to use those games
that count as
part of the proving ground to determine
who the best guy is going to be down the
stretch and if any team is going to
voluntarily maybe start a little slowly
in the hope of being better later yeah
it's them for strategic reasons it's the
patriots right no you're right and and
you know
again i'm not in favor of the platoon
thing but i i certainly could see new
england of all teams whether the stidhum
or cam newton was the starter
where you could see packages with both
of them on the football field i would
not be shocked i mean first off you know
you've heard me complain
since our years of working why is it
that the team that's dominated the last
two decades is also the team that's
willing to do trick plays and trick
formations consistently and not just in
like week three in a meaningless game
when they're up 21 nothing but like in
divisional playoff games and you know
big down 14. right down 14 to the ravens
and like hey we're going to throw past
the julian edelman and he's going to
throw it down the field what what it's
kind of a big moment so yeah i could see
them messing with defenses early on and
having a few well thought out packages
to where hey this they don't know what
to expect is this a screen is this a
quarterback throwback whatever it is i
would not be shocked and you're right
mike reese he seems to always have a
beat on new england and when he says
those things you're right your ears perk
up because you go he might know
something
and you know what if that uncertainty
that lingering uncertainty
is part of the ongoing effort to reshape
cam newton after nine years of
potentially being caught remember the
kyle love take yeah coddled in carolina
as the number one overall pick and now
he's in new england where they don't
cuddle anyone
maybe it's not enough to just let him
linger on the free agent market and have
him take a below market contract and
have him become humbled by those
circumstances maybe these circumstances
get him to the finished product where
he's got to fight and scratch and claw
and work for everything and he has to
push himself to a higher level it's not
just good enough to be better than jared
stidham and brian hoyer that's not your
bar that's right right so we want you to
push even more so we're gonna make you
think you're not separating from those
guys so you'll push even more
i mean that that that would go down in a
place like new england no doubt about
that you're right they're not going to
let him feel like oh this is yours your
king here relax you know take a you know
sit back in your chair you're the
starter no that that will not happen
they're going to continue to keep their
foot on the gas pedal as an organization
and they'll find the right pressure and
through their analysis of knowing cam
newton what they've heard being around
him now to where that right you know
pressure point with him is you know to
what you're saying to where ooh this is
good needling this is making him better
and not crossing over to going oh it's
actually a bad thing now we're ruining
the guy's confidence or you know we're
patting him on the back too much and now
he's too confident or whatever so uh i
would i would not be shocked by that
type of approach by new england
especially at this point of training
camp
it's what they did to tom brady for 20
years yeah sure right right they did it
for 20 years to the point where he
couldn't take it anymore he took it for
20 years but he he had enough of it and
now they've got a finished product of
tom brady down in tampa bay
who comes from two decades of the
needling and the strategic i mean that's
the thing
everything that team does is strategic
yes and the players are just the pawns
in affecting the strategy of putting
guys out there who are going to help you
win games so you do what you have to do
you tell the story all the time about
julian edelman or is it west west
right wes welker they want to get him
pissed off they know he plays better
when he's pissed off no doubt and uh so
piss him off yeah get him get him upset
and so that yeah i just i i feel like
this is all part of a broader play
to get the most out of cam newton and
also to just to test him just to see
what we have here because
you know if if he truly has matured past
the point where he's going to walk
around with that this isn't my day
demeanor if he throws an interception in
the first quarter we want to see that
come out we want to deal with that guy
in practice we want that guy to be fixed
now yeah so if he does throw an
interception on the first drive of the
game we haven't lost him mentally for
the rest of the game yeah that's right
you know you start to build that now
because you you know and your logic and
what new england knows is they're going
to go
well it's going to be a lot more
nerve-racking racking uh when we're down
10 in the afc championship game so if
you can't bounce back from you know this
interception here in training camp or
early on in the season and and build on
that to become better and more focused
and not you know like you said go down
this wormhole of maybe poutiness to a
degree at times uh yeah then he's not
going to be the guy for new england but
i think this is a motivated guy
certainly ready to go i think new
england wants to make it work and you
know the more thing the more i think
about it too you know mike is cam newton
jared siddom hey they're gonna learn the
meat and potatoes of that new england
offense but i even think like the
finished product of the offense whether
it's cam newton or stidhum i don't think
is gonna look a whole lot different i
don't i think it's gonna be a similar
look no matter what which is a good
thing if you're a patriots fan because
you don't have to worry about like right
now hey we're practicing one offense but
this guy's going to be the starter and
the offense is going to be different if
he's the starter no i don't think
that'll be the case stidham's a pretty
damn good athlete and he's a power
thrower like cam newton so i would think
they're gonna build it off of running
the football you know some trickery
behind the line of scrimmage some
movement in the quarterback and when
they do throw it it's not gonna be
julian edelman five yards over the
middle i think you're going to see more
20-yard 20-yard out routes comebacks
things like that
and possibly a platoon of stylum and
newton as we get into the games that
count coming up in fewer than four weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports